But if we can't figure out a way to make the calls easier,
then we're going to have to concentrate on having fewer calls.
Let me write down some possibilities for fewer calls and see which ones
you think make sense.
One possibility would be for each equation, like ODD plus ODD equals EVEN,
rather than evaluating them all N factorial times, maybe we could combine all of those
into one big equation.
Certainly that would result in fewer calls if we could figure out a way to do that
and still get the right answer.
Another way might be to, say, could we figure out a way to fill in one digit at a time?
Rather than do all N factorial permutations of digits,
if we could do one digit, see if that works, and if it does then do the next digit.
That would certainly help us do a smaller number of calls.
That's the approach we took with the zebra function where we started out
by doing all the permutations, and then we figured out let's go through
and if there's a contradiction, let's stop and not do the remaining ones.
The question is can we figure out a way to take that general approach for this problem.
Then the third approach would be to eval the formula once but eval it as a function
with parameters.
To do all the work of figuring out how to understand number plus number equals number,
do that just once and then call that function repeatedly with all the permutations.
There'd still be lots of calls to the function, but there'd be fewer calls to eval.
Tell me which one of these three do you think is the most promising.
Again, it's a matter of opinion.
You might have better ideas, but I want you to think about it
and tell me what you think.